un crimen que impactó al mundo 12 fueron
los tiros que recibió givenel Moisés en
su propia residencia el 7 de julio de
2021 su muerte fue recordada este
viernes dos años después por parte del
Primer Ministro Ariel Angie quien
manifestó el que es un sentimiento
latente este magnicidio aún no se ha
resuelto
para el gobierno es importante que echó
en el Moisés encuentre justicia estoy
haciendo todo en mi poder para ayudar al
sistema judicial a ir hacia adelante
dentro de Haití el caso parece casi
estancado no se ha convocado a una
juicio y ya son cinco los jueces que han
asumido la investigación uno de ellos
renunció después de que su asistente
muriera en condiciones confusas más de
40 sospechosos permanecen en una cárcel
de Haití Incluyendo a 18 antiguos
soldados de Colombia acusados del crimen
para Martín La viuda de Moisés la
solución pasa por un tribunal fuera de
su país
ante el bloqueo institucional de los
asesinos en el poder hace falta un
tribunal especial internacional en
Estados Unidos se han producido once
arrestos por este magnicidio y uno de
ellos ya fue procesado para la fiscalía
de Florida detrás de la muerte de maíz
hay un gran complot internacional para
contratar a mercenarios y acabar con su
vida para luego beneficiarse de
cuantiosos contratos de la
Administración venidera